take a look at this uh civics polling on
black lives matter from april 25th 2017
to may 10-22 we can see
net support
in uh just after george floyd was killed
hit 23 percent then the rioting started
jacob blake got shot and what happened
polling dropped even more and went down
to eight nine percent continued to fall
derrick chauvin convicted support for
black lives matter went down again
ahmed arbory verdict and they once again
dropped down to negative one percent net
support so you know what happens
every time now
we've had these three big moments jacob
blake's shot approval drops derek
chovin's convicted approval drops i
think they're losing the narrative war i
think we've seen them we're seeing the
media companies falter i think more
people are starting to share shows like
this or other people are calling it out
i mean you look at someone like jimmy
dore and there really is an economically
bipartisan anti-establishment emergence
because jimmy's you know a lefty guy but
he calls up the machine he calls out the
the establishment the author
authoritarianism i think regular people
if it's just fascinated after chauvin
was convicted
support tanked massively over the course
of a couple of months it went from six
percent net support down to three two
percent well because if you remember
right right before the the verdict for
derek shoving they had this riots there
was the riot in brooklyn center and that
was that that's the last ride i covered
it was april of of 2021 and so again i
mean yeah i mean now that was a bad case
where an officer is trying to use a
taser and accidentally choose a guy um
but
again what what happened in that riot
was people who had nothing to do with
kim potter or dante wright
had to suffer the negative consequences
because people were people were crazy
and going looting again i mean that
that it goes back to the two wrongs
don't make a right and that's why i'm
just against writing i wanna i wanna
pull up this story from komo news blm
co-founder admits she held parties at
mansion with donor funds
don't forget folks when you give money
to black lives matter you are supporting
parties
parties at a mansion baby yeah come on
it's studio
take a look at this this polling
and right now as of today civic says 44
opposition 42 support you can see that
black lives matter has gone underwater
in the past month or so and it's only
getting worse
well there you go
when more stories like this come out
when you find out nobody knows who's in
charge nobody knows where the money was
going they bought a big mansion had a
bunch of parties with your money
you know to everybody who watches this
show to everybody who watches shows like
stephen crowders or people who are
calling out the lies from black lives
matter
their money's safe they didn't make
donations but these these regular people
who don't pay attention who are like i'm
gonna make a donation and then did and
all they did was fund a bunch of parties
and a bunch of nonsense and a bunch of
violence
like out there waking up to it now like
the minnesota freedom fund i mean again
right
she wasn't the the candidate then but
she i mean a senator kamala harris
shared this
uh bail fund because that was that was
the current thing to do and you know a
lot of celebrities also you know
advocated for it and and donated to it
and and what happened what's even worse
in my opinion with that case is that
it's not even necessarily that i mean
the money was used to bail out actual
writers but in the months since then in
the year since then they've bailed out
some pretty egregious people who should
probably stay locked up
and yet they get released because they
have all this influx of cash all of a
sudden thanks to people like kamal hares
and then uh probably one of the
one case was that uh they they bailed
out this guy
um i forgot what the original charge was
for but he then went out and killed
somebody in a road rage incident shortly
shortly thereafter and the minnesota
freedom fund they put out a statement
saying
did say they confirmed that yes our
money was used to bail them out and then
they deleted it because they were i
think they were getting like too much
backlash so
this is the problem with with supporting
the current thing and the emotions
running high is that
you're right people don't
think through what's actually happening
because if you actually knew how like
peaceful protesters work and when
they're actually arrested by police a
lot of times they just get written a
ticket right they don't need they don't
need to get bailed out but because
someone wanted to do something and oh it
looks good and we're gonna virtue signal
and now people are dead i think it's uh
these leftist organizations know what
they're doing i remember
during occupy wall street there was the
national lawyers guild and they were
helping people that i had witnessed be
wrongfully arrested and the cops lied
and so i was like well that's cool
they're like lawyers and they observe to
make sure you know no bs from the cops
okay
then i saw them one day at a protest
where there was a like a bunch of right
wing people wanted to have a gap
have a protest or they wanted to have a
rally so the left showed up to oppose
that rally with violence the national
lawyers guild was on one side defending
antifa and i saw them and i was like how
come you guys are only observing one
side and they were like what and i'm
like shouldn't you be observing protests
in general why are you just with them
there was a group of black-clad people
wearing masks and sunglasses with
crowbars and two by fours and bats and
they were like
we're here to protect these protesters
and i'm like the guys over there with
shields are protesting i don't
understand why you're not protecting
them it's because these organizations
don't exist to protect the right to
protest they exist to serve the
revolution yeah absolutely i mean i see
those guys out there all the time and
they they definitely
are and look i'm not for you know police
cracking down on on people unjustly uh
it's just that in all the all the rights
that i personally covered it was always
rioters making the first move and police
responding in kind it's amazing watching
the right try to protest and having no
experience and no organizational power
and they think they can go up to these
cops and and and say things
i just i it's funny watching these
videos and you'll see these
conservatives being like yo yo why are
you arresting him didn't do anything i
don't understand like what's going on
and it's like wow that's exactly what
the leftists say
like these these people thought they
could show up and that the cops were
going to treat them
like oh we these guys support us
right no then you see those videos where
the people are throwing the blue lives
matter flag in the dirt and stomping on
it in front of the cops because they
finally realize like dude those cops
don't care about you dude
you go out protest that's why the left
has they've been organizing for decades
and they have infrastructure and money
behind them so when they get arrested
they all get bailed out even if they're
the most crooked and evil people you've
ever you ever heard of and then you know
magamima shows up waving a little flag
and i was in you know solitary yeah it's
not hard if you think about the allegory
like the french revolution i'm reading a
little bit about it like if they were
like and there were there were like
sympathizers to the revolutionaries in
the courts and that some of the french
revolutionaries were arrested and then
released you'd be reading about him that
is not even weird to me at all i can
totally see that happening as french
revolution they infiltrated the courts
they're working together so why is it so
hard to believe that that's happening
right now it's not it is hap it seems to
be happening right now i completely
agree with you i think people are in
denial about the fact that the left has
basically captured all of our most
authoritative institutions maybe not all
but some very very
uh some at the crux enough of them to
get away with rioting basically enough
of them to literally burn down buildings
and not face legal you know they set
fire to that church across from the
white house a historical church and then
the media and everyone's aligned against
trump over it they have so this is how
much institutional power the left has
and has had
they were able to intimidate a sitting
president of the united states
into going into the bunker of the white
house
and it was not criticized by the media
they were considered to be peaceful
protesters they praised it
exactly
and they laughed at trump right they
laughed at this
and then they you know they accused the
right of being insurrection and in that
and in that riot there were 60 secret
service officers who were
injured injured
around around 60 park police officers
were also injured and yet that's not
viewed as an insurrection and that's why
with you know the whole january 6th
discussion i mean for me i view it as a
riot i mean and i was against that
because riots are not good
but it's just it's i i don't care what
anybody has to say about january 6 if
they then look at what happened at the
white house
and they're you know and because i mean
that was also an attack against one of
the branches of government i mean it's
it's just so it's just i know we get
into the whole double standard hypocrisy
but
it's important to point that out because
when we're talking about the again the
history of our country that you have to
you have to we have to remember where
people stood
when things were on other sides of the
of the of the debate yeah well i
remember all throughout the summer of
2020 when the left was rioting i was
seeing hot takes from lefties who were
saying things along the lines of oh all
the 2a conservatives who said they
wanted to stand up to a tyrannical
government are awfully silent right now
arguing basically if anyone remembers
that conservatives should be laying down
their lives for a left-wing insurrection
then all of a sudden the left decides to
start pretending that they're against
insurrection labeling january 6th in
insurrection which is a bizarre thing
considering basically no one had weapons
we also know there was a
we're pretty sure based on the evidence
there was a lot of involvement from feds
there um and the narrative was not what
the media reported it as or has been
claiming it was but regardless now they
are once again in favor of insurrections
saying things like lori lightfoot for
example stating this is a call to arms
we have left-wing political leaders
saying we gotta fight we gotta fight um
what we need revolution etc she called
she called for arms and fights she says
we need to fight fight to victory that's
calling for weaponry yeah
jones got banned for basically the same
uh and chicago has plenty of them yeah
the government was set up so that we
don't have to go to another revolution
if we do it right although thomas
jefferson made it very plain that we may
have to and that you don't never do it
but we shouldn't have to we had a civil
war bro also well i want to mention this
i think what they were talking about was
more a revolt than a revolution so a
revolution is when you try to like
completely overturn the social order to
build something new whereas a revolt is
when you're trying to fight back against
something being are you like arguably
imposed upon you so you think this is
more of a revolt i think this is more of
a revolution i don't know i would argue
that what's happening i would argue that
it's a leftist revolution right they
want to create a new social order like
they don't even think that we should
recognize the differences between boys
and girls that's how bizarre and strange
the neutral orders seek to establish a
cultural revolution yeah a complete like
a complete a complete cultural and
political revolution yeah they just want
to overturn everything everything i mean
again the far left protesters in los
angeles they were calling for the
supreme court to be abolished
which is always funny because okay if
that happens you do realize then
abortion goes to the same that's the
whole reason why we're in this decision
in the first place they remember when
they were calling to abolish the senate
yeah i mean they're they're abolishing
they're abolishing left and right i mean
i'm open to change and revolution i
don't know a lot of a lot of anarchists
and libertarians probably like yeah
abolishing it for a while i thought we
should get rid of the uh house of
representatives because they're getting
bribed i'm like we need it but but what
i don't just want to get rid of it you
got to create something better if you're
going to change it you got to you got to
replace it like the founding fathers
didn't just fight and kill a bunch of
people and then be like what do we do
now like they had a plan they had a
bunch of paperwork they had they've been
debating for years and years together
and when it didn't work with the
articles of confederation they replace
it with something else and what we have
today i mean it's it's really
i mean
especially with the antifa
people and and and those and those guys
they
yes they are a threat and like
especially if they're motivated in
specific areas like the pacific
northwest but
they they also just hype themselves up
too much they they spray paint a cab on
the side of a wall and they jerk
themselves off on social media but say
look how awesome this is this is a
revolution you guys just spray painted a
wall right big wolf and then when it
gets below 40 degrees they they stay
home
a headless revolt this is from october
it's not even that long ago abolish the
senate
you know these people are just like
we've lost control of a body of power
abolish it yes okay
that's and again it's it's it's the
temper tantrum that that left us have if
we don't get what we want we want it to
go away or we'll take it or we'll
influence it through violence i wish
they thought of it more as a boat we're
all on that they don't like how fast
it's going so they want to
burn the boat as we're all on it and
like
it like no no no we gotta fix the boat i
wish that republicans felt that way too
yeah it'd be nice if you are on a boat
and there are people who are destroying
it with pickaxes you stop them from
doing it yeah thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there
you